do I look internet I feel like I'm the
star of a CollegeHumor youtuber parody
video right now hello welcome to my god
what month is it
September welcome to my September
favorites which is happening at the end
of the month like a real regular
youtuber I'm generic I did it okay
here are things I like and maybe you
should like them too I don't know you do
you sorry I got lost my people to
thoughts about a potential mountain dew
or you like the goat cheap animal joke
off of the you do you line whoo what a
field to have mentally product in for a
moment okay let's just do it yeah you
see yeah yeah yes yeah god damn it this
candle is amazing and guess what I made
it with the help of my good friend
Jocelyn Hughes
jessa news was one of the producers of
the grace Helbig show and she has a new
book out called DIY damn it and she's
got a bunch of videos here on YouTube
explaining how to do all of the DIY
projects that you see that look
effortless on Pinterest and she does
them in real life she breaks it down for
the broken-down girls she came over the
other week and we shot a video with
mamrie Hart in which she showed us how
to make these super easy soy candles and
we used pumpkin chuck and also we used
this pumpkin scent that she got offline
or no she went where did she get it I
don't know you have to watch the video
on Monday but it turns out they're super
stupid easy to make and they smell
better honestly than any Bath & Body
Works candle I've ever purchased in my
life I know that that is sacrilegious to
even say and that there are a bunch of
beauty gurus but super cute pitchforks
ready to burn my house down because of
that
and if you haven't you should go to DIY
damnit calm and
her book it's really like there's so
many cute pictures and I have a quote on
the back next yeah yeah yeah yeah this
is the double-ended lip gloss
it's from burr berbere 22 Couzens ah
chosen chosen son got chosen go am i
saying words or just things that sound
like racial slurs whatever this brand is
can you see that this is a dual tint
what is this god damn it eyes
collaborate with my brain on producing
thoughts dual lip tint and gloss and
this is in the color cashmere oh it's
distributed by the JoJo's Factory of
course it is I eat things and drink
things with complete disregard for
things that might be painted on my mouth
so I always try to opt for a lip stain
or a long-lasting lip tint this looks
like a very intense blood red but it
goes on much more mild than it looks and
I understand I should have probably worn
this today in this video to give you an
example and I didn't
so next yeah yes yeah yes yeah oh can
you see it damn it
this is bare minimum or bare minimal
that's a great name for a strip club try
to tell me it's not bare minerals stroke
of light eye brightener illuminator
regard excuse me what are cosmetics just
trying to see how many words that don't
make sense they can get away with on
their packaging cuz great job this is I
assume some sort of under eye concealer
brightener thing it makes your post
emotional cry faces look normal oh I
think I got this off of like hot local
rule Allah what are those website one
day they're offering really high-end
makeup products for a discounted price
which yes my first thought was some
stuff about them there's gotta be some
weird expired chemicals than those so
then my second thought was who really
cheap but I like this this seems to work
I don't sleep much and I've been extra
emotional lately so this
has become squad goals maybe that's why
I'm extra emotional is because I
consider an eye brightener my squad next
yeah
chippy is the idea I know if I wasn't
already a parody of everything everyone
hates about the internet when I started
this video yeah I get it
this is a ring that I bought off of Etsy
and I don't remember buying it I think I
actually meant to take it out of my car
on Etsy and instead I purchased it this
is all a lot I get it but I kind of like
it I am not good at layering a bunch of
jewelry and accessories so I opted
obviously for statement pieces yep it's
like a bold skull I guess the good thing
about it is that when you wear it it
makes you have to be very aware of your
hands and what you're doing because it
gets caught on everything and hurts when
you stab yourself with it so with me
potential kidnappers necks
yeah yeah yeah can you see it this is a
marble looking bold dish thing that I
got off of the home section of H&M calm
it cost $9.99 and I liked it very much
along with H&M home section in general
there's a lot of really really cute home
decor items for really really cheap that
are nice all the emotions yeah yeah
these are
new running shoes I got from Reebok I
got these for like 40 bucks on sale off
the Urban Outfitters the Urban
Outfitters I could be any age I got
these off of Urban Outfitters calm and
they were on sale for like 40 bucks can
you even believe these were on sale
these are like a neon orange color and
to be fair these are not the best
running shoes I've owned in my life
however I was looking more for bright
colored shoes because I've been running
at night a lot lately and I like being
able to have something on my person that
illuminates me for a potential terrible
drivers so I got these shoes and I liked
them I think there's fun and dumbs just
like me knack this sweatshirt yes the is
yeah yeah yeah this sweatshirt was given
to me by clashes calm which is a website
that has very um fun clothing mamrie
Hart has owned a few shirts from their
website and their line and I've always
loved them these are images of Elaine
from Seinfeld dancing which is just
really my spirit animal and this which
was really comfortable and it's great
quality and I like it very much so thank
you clashes if you're interested
websites down in the description
speaking of sweat shirts that are
available and great for you oh my god
these are my sweat shirts that I have
available at represent calm / its grace
5 they say no you got dressed in the
dark which I feels very appropriate
good Jesus Christ which I think it's
very appropriate for what I think inside
my head all day they are available for I
think only a couple more days on the
website they come in 4 different colors
and I love the sweatshirts they turned
out really really cute and if you have
purchased any the sweatshirts I've sold
off and represent in the past you know
that they are so stupidly comfortable
that it's worth
the commitment I am so out of breath
walking into the room and walking back
so make sure that you go get yours
before the sale ends they're only
available for a limited time and I would
love for you to have this in your life
because I like having it in mind next
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm Kezia this is
the October edition of Seventeen
magazine and look who's on the cover
Carla Rocklin so well the solid plus 45
social media faves throughout the entire
magazine I think this was so cool and
idiot thing there's a little bit about
me again
it's really cool this is the favorite
this month because it's awesome to see
people that I know on the front of
magazines and to be included in their
social media issue it's also really cool
that more traditional publications are
promoting the social media world like
this in the same way that they promote
the traditional media world I started to
read the article with Zoe and Tyler and
it's really really good so if you
haven't make sure you get a copy of this
plus it's also you know we read so much
stuff in a digital space and so
sometimes it's nice to like tangibly
have something to read do you know what
I mean there you go there are my
September favorites I hope that you guys
have been having a lovely month of
September subscribe and why they still
leave a comment down below and like this
video if you like it because I have been
pretty I just really kind of lukewarm
about doing favorite videos and so many
people do them here on YouTube but if
you find these interesting I know I find
other people's favorite videos
interesting let me know give me a thumbs
up or let me know in the comments and
I'll keep doing them if you hate them
let me know - it's good
I don't know max Q CI q c'kc you can't
see it but you can see it it's a live
show I'm gonna be at the Just for Laughs
comedy festival in Toronto and I'm going
to be doing my very first not too deep
live with Harley Morenstein from Epic
Meal Time and I think there are still
tickets available for you guys to come
see the show it is September 26 and I
would love love love to have you there
because this is something pretty new for
me I've been doing a lot of live shows
with Hannah Hart mamrie Hart but I've
never done one entirely by myself and
I've never done something like this with
Harley so it's gonna be really really
fun and I would love to have you there
it's also the day before my birthday so
it's really important for me to guilt
you into coming because of that so click
the link down below if you want to check
out the tickets because I think it's
gonna be really fun and if it's not fun
it won't be the worst thing ever
I can promise that can I